it was over
no one in the foundation from the
loneliest security guard
to the o5 council could quite explain
exactly what was over
if they were to hazard a guess a likely
answer would have been everything
it was generally agreed that the first
one to notice this
was dr victor balakirev dr balakirev
though a veteran of many a dangerous
experiment and not want to be easily
surprised
couldn't believe what his eyes or rather
his high power telescope were telling
him
what dr balakirev couldn't quite believe
was that a routine scan of the crab
nebula
revealed nothing but empty space where a
rather conspicuous and rather hateful
star was supposed to be
the alarm was raised a dozen more
telescopes were commandeered from
various facilities and agencies
and there was no small amount of
shouting and running around
the star however stubbornly refused to
reappear
despite dr balakirev's insistent claims
that
a star is in a bloody remote control you
don't just lose it
the next one to experience this strange
lack of all things strange
was d6821356 though he couldn't quite
appreciate the magnitude of the occasion
he didn't know he was supposed to be the
bait in what most assumed would just be
another futile attempt in an endless
series of failures
d6821356 also didn't quite know what to
feel when he entered the armored vault
to discover nothing more
than a badly mangled skeleton when the
acid bath was stopped
so uh what do you guys want me to do
with that
you have a bone to pick with me or
something
the joke was lost on the assembled
researchers who now had more important
things to worry about than d6a21356's
poor sense of humor so began
the end when scp-294 was prompted to
produce a cup of joe
it made a serviceable cup of cappuccino
which utterly
failed to contain any d-class flavoring
in scp-1981 ronald reagan spoke only of
evil empires
and managed to keep a perfect complexion
throughout his speech
scp-902 was opened and discovered to be
empty and no one could quite remember
why they feared it so much in the first
place
scp-076 was found to be similarly empty
though no one forgot what scared them
about it
when scp-1867 was asked if it realized
it was a slug
it didn't think for a second to object
since it very clearly was
besides it didn't understand the
question
scp-085 was gone from its canvas
and its inky plains and fields felt bare
and empty
without the presence of a young woman
who once inhabited them
they found the clothes which once
belonged to scp-1040 near the top of
mount everest
next to them a single word was written
in the snow
free around the world the echoes of the
end became
seismic shocks and no one was spared
from their influence
the church of the broken god was wiped
off the face of the earth
it isn't easy to maintain a religious
organization when all of your artifacts
crumble to dust
and it's even more difficult to do so
when half of those artifacts are inside
your head
marshall carter and dark limited
having lost most of their stock and
shortly after most of their members
soon faded into obscurity their once
busy clubhouse
a hub for all things mysterious and
expensive became a place for elderly
gentlemen to read the sunday paper in
peace
and doze in comfortable leather chairs
the global occult coalition after it
became clear that the threats it was
created to thwart were gone
was soon disbanded the budget once
dedicated to fighting the forces of the
unknown
was allocated to some of humanity's more
mundane
needs such as the prevention of global
warming and the development of more
advanced nuclear weapons
no word was heard from doctor one
detainment for a long time
a year after the end a new line of
doctor one detainment toys was released
while dr wondertainment's shooty man's
vengeance
was a perfectly decent game it was clear
his or her heart wasn't in it
when foundation agents arrived at the
current supposed location of the factory
they found nothing more than an ordinary
canned vegetable factory
the capital f was clearly no longer
needed
the serpent's hand lost a considerable
number of its members
and with no cause to rally behind was
destroyed
by the chaos insurgency the insurgency
itself
soon tore itself asunder like a mad dog
biting in its own innards
very few were left to be caught and
executed by the foundation
the members of are we cool yet never did
become
cool nobody was never heard from again
the unusual incident unit continued
chasing flying sources and reports of
bigfoot
this time entirely unrelated to scp-1000
its agents didn't really notice the
foundation
as resilient as ever was the last one
standing
as the years passed however the reasons
for its continued existence grew fewer
and fewer with all things anomalous gone
the foundation had lost its purpose
sight after sight was closed down
personnel were let go or in the case of
the few remaining d-class
terminated soon only one part of the
organization
remained it was the last meeting
of the o5 council there were no
heartfelt speeches or
commemorative plaques because even at
its end
the o5 council was a serious body of men
and women who didn't muck about with
nonsense
instead there were a few handshakes a
few quiet words
and mostly a whole lot of silence
finally
one at a time the former members began
to leave
until only two were left
so that's there
70504 running a cigarette smoking wasn't
allowed in the boardroom
but there was no one left to object
is this it everything we worked for all
our sacrifices
just worthless ask0511
staring glumly at the floor no i
wouldn't say that we kept the peace
while we were needed
and we did so as best we could we're
simply not needed anymore
shouldn't i be happy all of those
terrible things we had locked in are
gone
after all humanity is finally
safe from everything but itself
yes then why do i feel like some
toy used and abused and then discarded
when it's no longer useful
it's just the way things are we were the
jailers
the wardens holding back the storm now
all of our prisoners are gone
there's no need for wards and quiet days
come on let me buy a drink yeah
a drink would be nice
or ten hey i'm not made money you know
the two left and closed the door
behind them
you